[Symptoms in Schizophrenia, James D. Page, The University of Rochester]
[Schizophrenia (dementia praecox) is the most prevalent of mental disorders. About one per cent of the population eventually develop it.]
[It is essentially a chronic disease of unknown origin, characterized by marked personality disintegration.]
[In general appearance schizophrenics resemble normal individuals. All body types are represented. Distinction lies in their mental content and behavior.]
[Schizophrenics are divided into four clinical groups: simple, paranoid, catatonic and hebephrenic.]
[Apathy and absence of social interest characterize all types, especially the simple group who exhibit few additional symptoms.]
[Outdoor scene with some men seated on benches and some men standing.]
[Some men are pacing and others look disturbed.]
[Delusions and hallucinations occur in most hebephrenic, catatonic and paranoid patients.]
[The latter often give evidence of these symptoms by conversing or arguing with imaginary individuals.]
[A woman is seated in a rocking chair on a fenced-in outdoor porch. She seems to be talking to an imaginary person.]
[A man is standing inside a building near a window and looking outside. He is gesticulating and seems agitated.]
[A woman is standing outside. She has on a floral dress and a white cloth mask over the upper part of her face, with holes cut for her eyes. She is pointing and yelling.]
[Silly grinning and talking to oneself distinguish the hebephrenic.]
[A man is seated in a rocking chair with a blindfold over his eyes. He is laughing and talking to himself.]
[A woman is standing on the lawn outside.]
[She has on a mask with eyeholes and is wearing a floral dress. She is talking.]
[A man is seated in front of a brick wall. His eyes are covered by a white cloth blindfold.]
[He is talking, grinning, and laughing.]
[Mannerisms and motor stereotypes may occur in hebephrenics but they are essentially catatonic symptoms.]
[A man is seated outside with a brick building behind him.]
[He wears a mask with eyeholes, over the upper portion of his face. He is moving his hands nervously and constantly.]
[He is talking and repeatedly puts his hand on his mouth, then drums his fingers on the back of his other hand.]
[A man wearing glasses is standing on the lawn outside.]
[A brick building is behind him. He moves his hands in the same pattern repeatedly.]
[A man is seated in a chair outside. He moves his hands about and his fingertips flutter.]
[A woman in a plaid dress is seated in a chair on a porch.]
[Her face is half-covered with a white cloth with eyeholes. She moves her hands repeatedly near her face.]
[Then she holds her hands up and repeatedly cups her chin and face.]
[Some catatonics passively permit their limbs to be molded at examiner's will. This waxy flexibility is called cerea flexibilitas.]
[A man dressed all in white manipulates the arms of a patient. The patient is a male wearing a mask with eyeholes.]
[He allows the examiner to put his arms in any position without protest.]
[The examiner continues to manipulate the patient's arms and body in numerous positions. The patient passively allows the manipulation.]
[The patient is now seated in a chair on the lawn.]
[The examiner continues to manipulate the patient, moving his arms and legs into awkward positions.]
[The spontaneous shift from an induced pose to a more natural position is slow and gradual.]
[Following sequence records the lowering of raised arms after 1, 5, and 30 minutes.]
[A man is outside and his arms have been placed over his head by an examiner.]
[He is filmed at 1, 5 and 30 minutes after being manipulated as he slowly lowers his arms to a more natural position.]
[Other catatonics are extremely rigid and negativistic. They actively resist change.]
[A man is outside with a brick wall behind him. An examiner attempts to move the man's arm.]
[The man resists the movement.]
[The examiner also attempts to move the man's head as the man is seated outside, and the man resists.]
[The examiner attempts to move the man's head while the man is standing. The man resists all attempts.]
[Peculiar postures are assumed by some catatonics and often retained for days or months.]
[A man is outside standing beside a brick wall. He has a mask over his eyes. He is standing stiffly]
[The man is now facing the camera.]
[He is standing with his head bent down in front and is holding it with his hands on each side.]
[A woman is outside standing in front of a brick wall. She is wearing a floral dress and has a mask over her eyes.]
[Her arms are crossed over her chest and she is looking down. She doesn't move.]
[A person is seated in a chair facing away from the camera. The person is bent over with elbows on knees.]
[A woman in a floral dress is outside standing near a building.]
[She has a mask over her eyes and her arms are at her sides. She is bent slightly at the waist and is looking down.]
[A man is seated in a chair outside with a brick wall behind him. He is bent at the waist and looking down.]
[His hands are gripping the arms of the chair. He is motionless.]
[A man is seated in a chair outside with a brick wall behind him, wearing a mask with eyeholes.]
[He is looking down and his arms and hands are between his legs.]
[ A man is seated in a chair parallel to a brick wall. He wears a mask with eyeholes.]
[His legs and feet are drawn up beneath him and he is seated slightly sideways in the chair.]
[He moves restlessly and holds his head, covering his ears.]
[Echopraxia is a rare but striking catatonic symptom. Some inner forces appear to "compel" the patient to repeat the movements of others.]
[A man and a woman are seated outside on chairs.]
[The man makes movements with his hands and legs and the woman imitates him.]
[The woman's movements are somewhat exaggerated and she almost falls off the chair.]
[The woman continues to follow the man's arm and leg movements in an exaggerated style.]
[She tries to touch the examiner and almost falls over, so he helps her back into her chair. They continue the exercise.]
[The examiner rolls his arms in front of him and the woman copies him.
[The man brushes his shoulder and the woman copies his movement.]
[The man does the same with the opposite shoulder and the woman again copies him.]
[The man touches his face repeatedly and the woman imitates his movements.]
[The man brushes his hair back with his hand and the woman imitates him again.]
[In contrast the following case is one of pseudo-echopraxia.]
[Repetition is present but the performance, though spontaneous, is suggestive of voluntary imitation.]
[A male patient with his eyes covered by a mask is seated in a chair outside next to a brick building.]
[An examiner is standing next to him.]
[The examiner makes various arm, leg, and head movements and the patient imitates him.]
[The patient seems to be following the movements voluntarily.]
[The patient is now standing up and continues to imitate the examiner.]
[The examiner is now facing the patient and making more movements as the patient imitates him.]
[The examiner continues to make head, arm and other movements as the patient imitates him.]
[The examiner shakes hands with the patient as the film ends.]